[Music]
foreign
we are live on the electronic computer
machine I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Reuben report it is the return of the
Friday Round Table Extravaganza and
joining me is the host of prime time
with Alex Stein Alex Stein and host of
the Isabel of Isabelle Brown live
Isabelle Brown they both nailed it in
naming their shows Alex Isabel welcome
to the Reuben report thanks for having
us Dave
thank you
Isabel you've never been on the show
before so I want to give you 20 seconds
we've done things on your show and you
and I go a long way back but can you
tell people who you are what's going on
here and then Stein I'll let you do the
same even though you've been on before
heck yes 20 seconds on the clock let's
go I'm actually shocked I've never been
on the Reuben report officially because
we do so much together Dave but for
those who are not familiar with me or my
story my name is Isabelle Brown I am a
26 year old independent content creator
and full-time live streamer meaning we
do very similar to the Reuben report a
live stream every day covering the
biggest cultural and political issues
from a gen Z perspective on my video
platforms I'm also an author I do a lot
of public speaking but mainly I like to
just get up every day and tell people
the truth in whatever capacity I can be
it a 15 second Tick Tock video a three
hour long live stream a book or anything
else and fun little shout out here my
fiance actually works on Dave's team so
hi Brock I know you're sitting in the
control room somewhere but it's fun to
to be on the show and nice to meet you
you're engaged to that guy right over
there I know it's crazy that is wild uh
Stein that was very professional what
Isabel just offered us there uh can you
match that for the people that don't
know you I think most of them do though
first of all on Prime Time 99 Alex Stein
I'm a pimp on a blimp always eating
steak and shrimp I'm the host of prime
time with Alex Stein on Blaze TV I'm an
employee of radio broadcasting Hall of
Famer Glenn Beck so first of all let me
just tell you a little bit about myself
I'm Tucker Carlson's biological stepson
and I'm aoc's ex-boyfriend so if you
have an intro better than that I want to
hear it so ladies and Gentlemen let's
start the show
all right let's roll uh we got a couple
we're just recapping the week but it's
just such a freaking Fiasco out there I
want to start with this Eric Adams New
York City story uh because he basically
is telling people to now flee the city
then we're going to talk about all the
old politicians who are freezing up or
Meandering into the forest and the rest
of it uh we'll talk about who might take
Biden's spot oh and then Obama seems to
be having gay sex with some people while
smoking crack we'll also talk about that
no big deal uh but before we get to it
let's talk about Birch gold and then uh
we will do a program uh guys Congress
once again allowed itself to be pushed
into appeasing the administration and
raising the debt ceiling for the 79th
time Paving the way for continued
Reckless spending and further
devaluation of the dollar as our
national debt continues to Skyrocket how
are you protecting your savings well
Times Like These are a great reminder to
diversify a portion of your savings into
gold and you can do that with the help
of Birch gold here's the easiest way to
do it Birch gold will help you convert
any existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you don't pay a penny out of pocket
as bricks that's Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa band together
against the dollar more and more central
banks are diversifying you know what
they're buying you guessed it gold
follow their lead visit birchgold.com
Dave for your free info kit on gold
there's no obligation just information
with an A plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau and thousands of happy
customers Birch gold can help protect
your savings
birchgold.com Dave and now back to me
all right let's dive in guys a little
bit of info from ABC New York city mayor
Eric Adams says his administration is
straining
to keep up with the demand of supporting
thousands of Asylum seekers in the city
as he calls on the federal government
for more assistance according to the
mayor's office 57 200 Asylum Seekers are
currently in the city's care and nearly
a hundred thousand migrants have arrived
since last spring a portion of the
migrants have come from Texas as part of
Governor Greg Abbott's plan to bus
migrants to so-called Sanctuary cities
uh now before I let you guys chime in
we're going to throw to some video of
Eric Adams yesterday basically telling
everyone to get the F out let me tell
you something New Yorkers
never in my life have I had a problem
that I did not see and ended to
I don't see an ending to this
this issue
will destroy New York City
destroy New York City we're getting 10
000 migrants a month
one time we were just in Venezuela
now we're in Ecuador now we can Russian
speaking coming through Mexico now we're
getting western Africa now we're getting
people from all over the globe have made
their minds up that they're going to
come through the southern part of the
border and come into New York City
and everyone is saying it's New York
City's problem
every community in this city is going to
be impacted we got a 12 billion dollar
deficit that we're going to have to cut
every service in this city is going to
be impacted
all of us
I'm sorry but this is just funny and I
say that as uh Someone who lived in New
York City most of my adult life have
family I've got one well one family
member everybody has flight except for
one I got one cousin who's still stuck
there but he doesn't see an end to this
he's the one who made it a sanctuary
City he wanted to bring these people in
he also seems to be confused as to who's
mayor which is him because he would be
the one that might be able to do
something about this Isabel
it's really easy to become a sanctuary
City Dave when you expect that all of
these people are going to stay put in an
Arizona or Florida or Texas where you
don't have to touch it with a 10-foot
pole and you can stand on a moral High
ground but I think not to be crass about
this you f around and you find out when
your Northern City uh decides to become
a sanctuary City and has to deal with
the ramifications of that it is asinine
to me that 3 000 migrants are staying in
the Roosevelt Hotel alone in Midtown
Manhattan and we're expecting that
there's not going to be ramifications in
the Health Care system and the crime
rate in just day-to-day life in cities
like New York I see this all the time in
Denver where I grew up uh now downtown
Denver looks a lot more like Skid Row in
La than anything I recognized where I
grew up so I think a lot of these cities
are going to have to find out the hard
way what their policies actually look
like but they turn to the federal
government for help which is what you
just heard mayor Adams say there the
federal government is the ones actually
welding open the gates at the border
wall in States like Arizona so don't
count on them for any sort of change in
Behavior here if anything they're only
going to make it worse
Alex was that reaction and that speech
by Eric Adams just kind of inevitable it
was like of course this was ultimately
going to be what happened and again as
much as I loved New York City at one
time my life it's kind of like well you
guys just deserve this now and this had
to happen
well first of all here's my hot take I
actually agree with Eric Adams those
buses need to be going to back to Mexico
not up to New York City I know it's
funny you're a sanctuary City and we're
sending people up there we're trying to
troll you know Governor Abbott thinks
he's so cute sending all these people to
New York City first of all New York City
is the most important city in the world
in my opinion and definitely an American
after 9 11 the entire world rallied
around New York City and it became like
this great place tourism was up but now
with bail reform like they're letting
criminals out on RoR bonds so it's like
it's like a purposeful demolition of it
and if they're not going to stop it
themselves there's nothing we can do
about it so it's a Bus full of
immigrants obviously that's terrible but
Eric Adams In that clip he talks about
how these immigrants aren't from all
from Ecuador their Northern African
they're Russian speaking so they found a
loophole and until we close that
loophole it's only going to get worse
because in Texas it's so bad I mean we
just laugh at this oh your your schools
are going to be over inundated with uh
Spanish-speaking children well that's
been happening in Texas for the past 30
here so you know good luck you know
figure it out so I'm a little empathetic
only in that those buses are going in
the wrong direction
Isabel you have your finger on the pulse
of what young people are thinking young
people seem to be voting for Democrats
but young people also wanted to at one
time move to cities like New York City
and and follow their dreams and do
whatever it is that they want to do is
this the type of thing that will wake
them up or is it just still just too far
gone well first Dave I'll say it's
interesting I hear that all the time
young people are voting for Democrats in
droves that's actually not statistically
completely accurate if you look at Exit
polling for Gen Z voters which by the
way is through the roof in terms of
voter turnout we had the second highest
youth voter turnout ever in a midterm
election in 2022 so we're voting and
we're excited about it but if you look
at the exit polling from 2018 to 2020
and then 2020 to 2022 you're seeing
young people vote in a straight line
more with the Republican party and more
towards conservative principles so the
idea that it's overwhelmingly already
won by the Democrats with Gen Z really
is a logical fallacy that I hope more
conservatives are able to wake up to and
Inspire more young people to embrace
conservative principles but this is just
one of a Litany of things that I think
young people are waking up to not so
much about the Democrat Party but just
about how politicians in general really
aren't interested in solving the biggest
problems that are impacting our
day-to-day lives we have in many
instances kind of a una party in
Washington DC that says they're going to
take action on these things on one side
or the other but then they sit on their
hands when they have the capacity to do
something in power and run on that same
platform two years four years six years
later to try to convince us that they're
the best solution to the problem clearly
if we have Rising violent crime rates if
we have problems with illegal drug
smuggling and Firearms smuggling into
the country if we have human trafficking
happening in droves across the southern
border that's probably going to impact
us as well and taking those jobs from
American citizens taking away our
opportunities it's impacting our culture
and we're starting to realize
politicians from both sides really
aren't the people solving this problem
from your mouth to God's ears May the
young people wake up but from young
people to old people let's talk about
some of the geriatric class that seems
to be governing us at the moment I'm
going to throw to a couple videos here
but I want to start with this video
because I was off the grid for August so
we never covered this but this was the
end of July the first time I suppose the
first time that publicly Mitch McConnell
just seemingly froze up or had some sort
of medical emergency stroke God knows
what I know the doctor said he was
dehydrated but here's the first time
that this happened this was the end of
July finishing the NDA
this week has been good bipartisan
cooperation
and a string of
um
anything else you want to say I'm sure
let's go back to you
do you want to say anything else to the
Press
go ahead John
Alex I'm going to throw to you possibly
not to be funny for a moment but like I
mean we can make the jokes about it sure
and we will I promise you but like what
is going on here why are we allowing
this to happen I mean are we do we just
deserve this because these are the
people that we put in and it is what it
is
well first of all he should be in basic
I mean it seems like he should be in
hospice care and these are the people
that are running our country so I mean
it's really sad and then you know Dianne
Feinstein she's a thousand years old I
mean I don't know why these people
aren't on a golf course and that's one
thing I'm kind of empathetic I don't
know why Donald Trump doesn't go play
golf I mean now they're trying to arrest
him I mean I love him that he's a
fighter but these people are old Joe
Biden's going to be 81 in 2024 I mean
obviously he's not gonna be able to run
I don't think so so I don't just I don't
understand why we just let all these
geriatrics run the country uh it's kind
of really it's elder abuse in my opinion
and their families should be held
accountable
um and I just at this point they have
all the money they need they have lots
of power go on vacation like go take a
break but sadly they're just you know
running the Deep state that is making
America uh you know a nightmare to live
in at the moment
Isabel is that the Twisted part like
it's not just that you see him
struggling there but that the people
around him clearly nobody really cares
about him he's just the vessel for them
to attain some level of power so they
just want to keep his old bones standing
there basically that is exactly correct
Dave I always like to say Washington DC
looks a lot more like Weekend at
Bernie's than anything we could possibly
imagine these days because you're
literally looking at people who have
been in office Mitch McConnell for
example he's been a senator since
1985. since 1985 I was born in 1997 not
to make anyone feel old watching this
but that's ridiculous to me that we're
still counting on these people to fix
the problems they promised they were
going to 10 12 30 years before I was
even born like it's insane to me but
you're starting to see this not just
with Mitch McConnell you see it with
Dianne Feinstein being told in her ear
by one of her aides on the senate floor
there how to vote on certain legislation
you obviously see it with the president
of the United States how did it take
them 45 50 seconds of complete silence
and glassy eyes to even ask silently in
the background uh is he okay is he okay
should we get something should we take
him off the screen uh it's just
ridiculous to me that this pattern of
behavior continues to happen but when
you keep electing people like Dianne
Feinstein for example who was born
before the invention of the ballpoint
pen of the microwave oven of the
trampoline I don't know what else you
can possibly expect
the trampoline I would have thought the
trampoline would have been around for a
long time like when people didn't know
that way
um Isabel bringing the knowledge but
then it happened again and the doctor
said he's dehydrated but but look at
this this is just last week
running for re-election in 2016.
that's true
did you hear the question Senator
running for reelection in 2026
all right I'm sorry you all we're gonna
need a minute
Penny yeah
okay
somebody else have a question please
speak up
I mean it really is just insane it's as
if I was speaking and then
Dave Dave
if somebody has a question please feed
God
oh okay
just you see what we did there guys Emmy
award-winning Reuben report
Alex
anything else on this
It's just sad I mean he needs to really
get some if that's how he's acting in
public imagine what he's like behind
closed doors I mean I only imagine that
is much worse and probably has a nurse
to them all the time I mean really sad
Isabel what do you think about just sort
of like the generational shift on this
that it's this baby boomer gen that he's
not even baby boomer and he's he's from
I guess what they call the greatest
Generation before that but they are hung
uh hanging on so long or I guess he's
the top of the Boomer supposedly but
whatever it is like these people are
just hanging on so long that they
haven't let the Gen X guys the the say
35 to 55 year olds who should be in
charge right now really take over thus
it pushes your generation back further
and and that really is almost the
Genesis of all of our problems right now
it is and I always like to remind myself
when I get frustrated thinking How could
somebody possibly just want to keep
doing this over and over for the rest of
their life the only thing that's more
corruptable than money is power and
absolute power corrupts absolutely which
is why you see our second oldest Senate
since 1789 our third oldest house uh in
all time American history because these
people grab onto power and they just
can't let go and eventually do become a
vessel for other people to seek power in
Washington DC I never noticed this in
that second clip until I just saw it
again from Mitch McConnell that his Aid
his staffer actually Winks at the camera
we're gonna need a minute guys so it's
this open joke that we're all aware of
and everyone's thinking but nobody's
willing to talk about it meanwhile 70
percent of Americans think that the Two
Front Runners for president are too old
to be president we think that our
Congress is far too old to continue
holding on to power but a generational
shift doesn't look like handing the
reins even to Millennials or gen Z like
most people think it literally is
handing the reins to people my parents
age to take over the country and we're
still uncomfortable doing that in
Washington for some reason yeah it's
also interesting you know you mentioned
absolute power corrupts absolutely and
it's like McConnell has had so much
power for so long and yet in those
freeze up moments and we've seen it with
Biden too there is this fear in there
because he knows something is wrong the
people around him don't care and it
becomes this self-fulfilling prophecy we
will basically run this guy into the
ground but but speaking of people that
are holding on too long Joe Biden
everyone knows he's not cognitively
right it is just it is just known it's
now showing in the polling even on the
Democrat side and it does seem like
maybe they are Paving the way for him
not to be the nominee uh his vice
president Kamala Harris who was polling
at one percent in her own party when she
dropped out of the race last time uh
she's starting to talk about what it
might be like you're 58 now if you win
the second term as you and the president
are running to do he would be 86 at the
end of it The Wall Street Journal had a
poll showing two-thirds of Democrats say
Joe Biden is too old to run again
are you prepared to be
commander-in-chief yes I am if necessary
but Jill Biden is going to be fine and
let me tell you something I work with
Joe Biden every day
the work that under Joe Biden's
leadership our Administration has
accomplished is transformative
I think the American people most of all
want a leader who actually gets things
done
listen I will give credit where
creditors do she strung together two
sentences that actually made sense so
that's worth something uh Alex this
thing like Joe Biden will be fine it's
just it's just ridiculous because a he's
obviously not fine on face value but
also he it's one trip it's one broken
hip away from ending like it could
literally end while we are talking right
now
well I think they're going to put him
through some sort of kind of humiliation
ritual and make him step down because
all of Hunter Biden's crimes I mean
everybody knows the laptop's real even
though all of the social media companies
you know came together to say that that
was Russian disinformation so at some
point I think the DNC is not going to
keep defending Joe Biden they're going
to say hey we made you president you
know
we did you a favor now you just need to
go on and they're probably gonna then
the future president probably is going
to Pardon him Kamala Harris I know this
is total conspiracy but I think that
they're going to do something to
humiliate Joe Biden because Obama does
not like Joe Biden in my opinion and I
think the future president it would
probably be Michelle Obama if she didn't
have a dong so yeah I don't know I mean
I just I don't have a lot of Hope in uh
Joe Biden in the future but uh he's
definitely not running in 2024.
I'm going to not ask Isabel about that
remark rather
nobody likes Kamala and the Democrats
have a real problem with that don't they
they do she's completely unelectable I
don't know if either of you have ever
seen the TV show Veep but I think we are
headed for an almost plot for plot
re-enaction of what's happening on my
favorite Washington DC show the
president will step down within the last
year for whatever reason maybe he has a
stroke maybe it's a fallen bad hip maybe
he passes away I mean at literally
anything is possible between now and
2024 obviously the vice president Kamala
Harris will become president but she
will be unelectable by her own party in
the primaries the exact same way faux
president Selena Meyer was in the TV
show and some Grand hero will sweep in
at the last moment to save the day to
save America from radical Maga white
supremacist extremism and I actually
think you're right on the nose Alex I've
been predicting it would be a Michelle
Obama for a very very long time they're
putting her on all of the late night
comedy shows on all of the lifestyle fun
podcasts not to talk about politics but
to talk about the kids being grown up
where they're going on vacation what
cocktail they made at dinner last night
humanizing the Obamas in a really
relatable way very intentionally leading
into the next election and God help us
solve my other prediction is that Gavin
Newsom likely will be the nominee for
vice president of the United States
sorry Dave I know you just fled
California
but they're doing the same thing with
him making sure he's very likable
relatable electable especially on social
media yeah let me show you one more clip
of Kamala because she's she's ready
good
we will win the election you will win we
will win re-election
there's too much at stake and the
American people know it
Alex I can't believe it this is the
election where there's too much at stake
I've always been waiting for the
election when somebody would tell me
there's a lot at stake here and if we
don't vote for them all hell is going to
break loose
well every election is the biggest
election and they're probably actually
right I mean right because it affects
our life uh most recently but uh Kamala
Harris what she got her job by being a
concubine with a Willie Brown the mayor
of San Francisco and then it's funny
that that connection to Gavin Newsom who
would sleep with I guess it was his top
staffer's wife while he was the mayor of
San Francisco so Gavin newsom's a
scumbag I mean to do that to your friend
or a person you work with and that just
you know totally gets swept under the
rug so I believe the Deep stable if they
don't care about that you know they like
guys with uh sexual uh you know bad
stuff in their past you look at Bill
Clinton so yeah Gavin Newsom fits their
profile you know perfectly for who
should be the next president even though
he's white comes from an affluent
families not Multicultural at all he
doesn't represent uh progressivism
really you know at all but yeah I think
Isabelle's right that he's probably
going to be the nominee uh in 2024.
wouldn't that be something the perfect
chef's kiss ending to all of this is
that they somehow push Kamala Harris the
black woman out of of the way so that
they can bring in the rich white man I
mean it's just so perfect it's
ridiculous but you mentioned sexual
proclivities and we had it internal
debate here this morning at the Reuben
report whether we were going to talk
about this ridiculous story but maybe
Obama's gay and maybe he was smoking
crack with the gay dude and whatever so
okay it's Friday let's do it this man
named Larry Sinclair who Larry Sinclair
went on Tucker Carlson's show and he
claims that about 30 years ago he was
having sex and snorting coke and smoking
crack with Barack Obama I just want to
say one thing before we throw to this I
remember this is going to sound nuts but
I remember back in 2008 or so seeing
this guy Larry Sinclair there was a
video of him on MySpace that was going
viral saying this exact same thing so it
isn't as if I swear to you I remember
seeing that so it isn't as if this guy
just magically appeared out of nowhere I
don't know if he's completely insane I
mean something doesn't seem quite right
I've given you enough of an intro video
you're just a guy who's in town for the
night and it sounds like you're looking
to party yeah hold up in a bar outside
and there's this guy that's introduced
to me as Barack Obama I had given Barack
250 dollars to pay for Coke I start
putting a line on a CD tray to snort and
next thing I know he's got a little pipe
and he's smoking so I just started
rubbing my hand along this thigh to see
where it was going and it went the
direction I had intended it to go even
though you had sex with him twice you
did cocaine with him watched him smoke
crack twice you had no idea who he was I
had no idea who he was Enthusiast the
obvious question what was Obama like on
crack
um is it your sense that that sewer bomb
is just transactional or these bisexual
or like what is this it definitely
wasn't barack's first time and I would
almost be willing to bet you it wasn't
as long
the guy's running for president and
credible information comes out that he's
smoking crack and having sex with dudes
that seems like a story well it would be
a story of the media really cared about
telling people the truth
all right I I want to say I I don't know
if it's true in a certain way I don't
care if it's true I don't care if
Obama's gay my husband's gay not that
there's anything wrong with that
um but there's something here because if
this man had said he was having sex with
say Donald Trump or Mitch McConnell or
insert any Republican this would be the
front page of the New York Times every
day endlessly Isabel Obama smoking crack
go
time I watched that video Dave I
probably have watched that promo 45
times at this point I just get a kick
out of Tucker trying not to laugh it's
the first time I've ever seen a little
smile at the corner of his mouth when
he's really seriously listening to
someone because you're right the open
joke is this would be the highlight
number one trending thing on every
social media platform this would be 24 7
on every News network and on the front
page of every newspaper if we were
talking about a republican candidate for
president or even a former president at
that I do find the timing awfully
coincidental while the Obamas are doing
this glorifying press tour of their
family so perhaps there is some weight
there uh we'll just have to see if the
truth does eventually come out but it's
it's awfully interesting to me how the
media is refusing to acknowledge this
conversation and how we have to bring it
to Independent Media sources and that's
true of so many important stories going
into 2024 stop listening to the
mainstream cable television if you want
the full truth Alex I know you're a drug
slash racism expert there's sort of like
a funny race piece of this which is that
Sinclair is saying he snorted the coke
while Obama smoked the crack I don't
know something seems interesting to me
about that
well put on your tinfoil hat please
because this is why my biological
stepfather had Larry on the show now
alone everybody saw in 2008 you know
this press conference when before before
Obama was President he said that he did
these things right everybody kind of
swept it under the rug because there was
not a lot of you know corroboration to
the story it was just one guy's word
against Barack Obama and obviously
you're going to believe a senator not a
crackhead but recently letters have come
out from Barack Obama's ex-girlfriend
talking about how he fantasized about
having gay sex now I don't care if
Barack Obama's gay actually I think that
makes him more likable that makes him
more authentic we said oh I'm a gay man
and I'm married to you know Mike but I'm
not I'm not saying that that's true or
false what I am saying is true real
quick I just want to end it on this
in his own autobiography he said that he
experimented with cocaine and marijuana
so he's tried drugs oftentimes we talk
about uh you know race problem in this
world I think it's that we have a lot of
fatherless non-traditional homes and
Brock comes from that upbringing he
wasn't raised by his dad he was raised
by his mom mainly and so oftentimes
those people use drugs so the idea that
Barack Obama uses drugs he smokes
cigarettes I think he did I think that's
true what did he do with Larry Sinclair
I don't know is he gay probably and
that'd be cool if he would just admit it
so I mean that's just how I feel about
Barack Obama and those are the cold hard
facts that I think but also I'm a
conspiracy theorist so you know take
that for what you will well you either
tin foil hat on though Alex because
Beyond just the letters he actually
tweeted out that he was upset seeing all
the books that were being removed from
elementary schools here in Florida Dave
uh that you're very familiar with the
content of because those were the Books
That Shaped his childhood if you know
anything about those books they are
graphic gay porn graphic novels so is
that really the book that you want to
say shaped your childhood former Mr
President I don't know speaking of those
letters let me let me read you just this
segment this is from the post-millennial
in a letter to former girlfriend Alex
McNair Obama allegedly confessed that he
had repeatedly fantasized about engaging
with men in sexual relations Garrow told
tablet the letter he had received from
McNair had an entire paragraph redacted
when Garrow asked she responded it's
about homosexuality Garrow said that
around when his book Rising Star came
out in 2017 McNair sold the originals
which ended up at Emory University
Garrow said that when Emery got the
letters they put out a press release
stating we've gotten these rare Letters
by Barack Obama but did not mention any
paragraphs that were too sensitive the
writer sent his friend to the Emory
archives where he copied down by pencil
the paragraph that was redacted in which
garro says Barack writes to Alex about
how he repeatedly fantasizes about
making love to men I think it's both
it's interesting because you both said
the same thing which obviously I agree
with which is that like you don't
personally care I don't think most
people would personally care if it
turned out that Barack Obama was
actually gay or bisexual or something
like that but it's more about just the
general lack of authenticity of these
people that we just can't take anymore
is that is that a fair assessment as
well absolutely I am sick and tired of
fake politicians telling me fake
promises on campaign trails to create
their own personal agenda that's going
to give them wealth Fame and Fortune I I
just don't think the average American
resonates with that one bit and the same
can be said about the media too which is
why you see independent content creation
and people in the spare bedroom of their
house with a home studio talking about
this stuff rising in the interest of the
American people rather than tuning into
multi-million dollar companies
authenticity is everything going into
2024 and I hope that more people pay
attention to that Alex I believe you
said the word dong on the Reuben report
for the first time so I'll give you the
final word
well first of all nobody would care if
Barack Obama was a homosexual and I
think it's pretty obvious that if you
write a letter to your girlfriend you're
trying to like send a dog whistle that
maybe you're bisexual so and if you are
good for him not that there's anything
wrong with that so uh Barack Obama's
probably you know running the Deep state
right now uh so he's still probably very
powerful so it's probably not good that
he's a liar and that his Chef is just
dying under weird circumstances and that
people can't find the truth about that
so yeah no he's the new Hillary Clinton
2.0 the new Bill Clinton 2.0 so yeah I
think in this world that we're living in
I said it to you earlier all we can do
is laugh at this world we need to become
a little clown pilled because these
politicians Barack Obama they do not
care about us uh Joe Biden on everybody
and they get away with crimes that we
never would
and uh we live in a two-tier justice
system and that's just a hard reality
and life's not fair and uh we got to
kind of laugh away the pain Alec this
might be the time to say that you have
no intentions of killing yourself
no no Hillary no I'm not any list I love
you Baroque please I'll become your Chef
I'll do whatever you tell me to do right
now I'll go cook you omelettes as long
as you don't kill me please don't Alex
Isabel thank you have a great weekend uh
we've got a post game show coming up on
locals reubenreport.locals.com if you
want to offer Insight ask me questions
uh reference Dongs
for everybody else have a good weekend
in about 30 seconds on local see ya
did you hear the question Senator
running for re-election in 2026
all right I'm sorry you already need a
minute
[Music]
and he is here to commit to work with
the governor and the the delegation
[Music]
this is a president that is committed to
infraction
[Music]
foreign